.
What we will do in this presentation is to graphically draw some lines
Using x and y intersections of the line
At first, the line is defined by two points
If you find two points - if you are able to set two points
On-line, you will be able to connect between them and continue
Both directions
And so you draw the line
What I will do in this show - the two points that are
I will choose them as line intersections
These are two of them
There is an x-junction and a y-intersection
These are the points where
Lines intersect with x and y axes
To illustrate this, this is the x-axis
On the graph sheet
That is the x-axis
It's continuous
That is the x axis
Here, in the center, which is heading up
The bottom is the y axis
That is the y axis
I do not think you can see what to write
That's the y axis
Let me explain what I mean by x and y intersections
Let's do part a
Part a
I will do it in a different color, not the same color
Intersections
Part a, we have equation y = 2x + 3
First, let's think about what will happen when x
= 0
When x = 0
When x = 0, how much is y?
y = 2 × 0 + 3
Well, 2 × 0 = 0
If y = 0 + 3 ie y = 3
If point x = 0, and y = 3, that is
Check the equation
Or it exists on the line defined by this equation
If point .3
Let me see her
Point 0.3
Now note, this point - when x = 0
It lies on the y axis
This is called a y intersection
When x = 0
But it is called the y intersection because it is located on the y axis
It is the intersection of the line with the y axis
Let's do the same thing now with the x axis
Let's put y = 0
If y = 0, we will have 0 = 2x + 3
We can subtract 3 from both ends of the equation
We get 3 = 2x
Now divide both sides on 2
We get 3/2 = x
And a 3-2 score of 1-1
We know that the point is 3/2, 0, is not it?
The second point was y = 0
We know that a set of x and y values ​​are also achieved
This equation
Or that this point also falls on the line
3/2 - and remember that it is equivalent
-1 1/2
Located here, y = 0
This was the second point we created
When y = 0, in this case we deal with the x intersection
We cross the x axis
That is the x intersection
If you want to draw the line, it will look like this
Approximate, I will reach these points then
continue
Continue both ways
Both directions continued indefinitely so I had
Painted line
Let's solve more
I do not want to be a mess here
Let me erase all this
Let me
Let me erase this also
You can stop the show whenever you want, if you want to stare at it - ohh
I did not have to do that
See the axes
I will redraw the axes
I will redraw them again
Good end
This is the first axis, x-axis
This is the y axis here
Let me do part b, it seems that b
Interesting
b is 6x - 1 = 2y + 3
Let's look at the case where x is = 0
When x = 0, the result of equation 6 will be
X -1
is not it?
Because this is 0
6 × -1 = -6 = 2 - call me
Divide it - +2y + 6
You hit 2 × y and × 3
Then we can propose 6 from both parties, and so
We get -12
-12 = 2y
I put six of the parties up until I moved this 6
To the left side
We subtract 6 from here, and these disappear
We subtract 6 from here, and get -12
Divide both sides on 2, and get 6 = y
If the first point that we have and know it lies on the line are
x = 0, and y = -6
That is the intersection of y
Now, let's see what happens when y = 0
Return to the original equation
We have - let me write this in a different way - when y
= 0, we have 6x - 1
Let me make up for that
6x - 6 = 2y
Well, y = 0
So we have 2 × 3
This all becomes 3
Will equal 6
Let's subtract 6 from both parties - or let's add 6 for both
The two ends of the equation
I want to get rid of them here
I need to add 6 until it becomes 0
We get 6x = - we add 6 to the right side
We get 12
And we get x - we divide both sides on 6, and we get the
x = 2
If the other intersection is x = 2, and y = 0
We have x = 2, and y = 0
Here
This is the x intersection
Then our current line, we connect points
It will look like this
We clearly have a problem drawing a straight line but I do
I think you understand the idea
Two points define the line
Let me have one more
I can solve it at the top here, in these
Area
Let's solve the part d
Part C can be solved if you want extra exercise
Part d, we have x + y = 8
It's really, really straightforward
When x = 0, how much is the value of y?
If it is 0, then y = 8
Then when y = 0, how much is the value of x?
Well, you can cover this as well
You get x + 0 = 8
If x = 8
These were direct
If our first point is 0.8
0.8
This is the y intersection
Then we have point 8.0
8.0
This is a x intersection
Then we can reach the points
It seems so
Now let's solve this issue
At a local grocery, the strawberry price was $ 3.00 per
Lbs and banana price $ 1.00 per pound
If I had $ 10 to pay between strawberries and bananas, draw
A composite graph of everything I can buy
I would pay exactly $ 10
Let me draw the axes
And make sure it's good and packed
This as you remember is the horizontal axis
This horizontal axis
But for pleasure, instead of being called x axis
I'll call it the strawberry hub
Strawberry hub
In fact let me name it, Axis S, where it's dedicated
For strawberries
Let s = number of strawberries
the strawberry
I think you realize what I'm doing
And b will be the number of banana pounds
the banana
Let me put the b axis
I will set the number of banana pounds on the vertical axis
This is the axis of b
b Ratio to bananas
Okay
Strawberry Price $ 3.00
Well, this is not the number of strawberry beads
It is the number of pounds
Let me erase this
These are the number of strawberry pounds
We will not walk with the number of strawberries
But with strawberry pounds
These are banana pounds
this is good
Strawberry price $ 3.00 per pound, bananas
Its price is $ 1.00 per pound
How much will I spend?
I will spend $ 3.00 × the number of strawberries
Because their price is $ 3.00
Well, I will spend $ 3.00 × the number of pounds
The strawberries are priced at $ 3.00 per pound + $ 1.00
Ø Number of banana pounds
It is required to spend $ 10.00 on both
This is worth $ 10
If 3 × strawberries + strawberries
Bananas = 10
1b is equal to b, so I can rewrite it b
+ b = 10
Now let's fix it
Let's look at the situation where there is no strawberry
The situation in which there is no strawberry
That is, strawberries are 0 pounds
How to become an equation?
3 × 0 + b = 10
This is 0
And b = 10
Now I will put 0 pounds for strawberries
I get 10 pounds of bananas
If I have 0 pounds of strawberries, I will get 10
Bananas
Now what about the rest?
What did not I have a banana?
I'll get 0 pounds of bananas
Now let's make up for here
We have 3 x strawberries + 0 lb pounds
Bananas = 10
This is 0
Divide both sides on 3
I can - if I do not have a banana - I'll get 10/3
Strawberry pound
Or this equals 3 1/3
Point 3 will be 1/3 pounds for strawberries, and 0
Lbs for bananas
If 3 1/3 pounds
Strawberry, 0 lb banana
Then we can connect the line
This line I will draw, I will paint it
In the first quarter
Because I can not have negative bananas
I will not sell negative bananas
I can not have a strawberry
We are not talking about selling strawberry negative
I can only buy this stuff
This is the amount I will buy
Let me get the points out
This is structured because this line illustrates all
Possible compounds of strawberries and bananas
For example, this point - I do not know if I am
Draw it exactly - it looks like I took 5 pounds
Of bananas, and less than two pounds of
the strawberry
That's what I'm telling him
If you take 3 pounds of strawberries, if you take
Exactly 3 pounds of strawberries, so I can take one ban of bananas
Each point here represents a compound
I can get it for $ 10
.